we are a divided country we're told
people blame the media others
politicians but to quote former
president obama
don't blame me instead put it on
identity politics
when i hear people say they don't like
identity politics they don't like
i think it's important to remember that
identity politics doesn't just apply
when
it's black people or gay people or women
no you know
the folks who really originated identity
politics were folks who said
you know three fists clause and all that
stuff that that was identity politics
that's still that's still out there he's
dead right the past was super
racist just ask democrats who went to
war to defend slavery
but that was then but now obama seems to
be arguing around
a current problem kind of like when
faced with islamic terror
you say this lest we
get on our high horse and think this is
unique to some other place remember that
during the crusades and the inquisition
people committed terrible deeds in the
name of christ
it's the same argument but i don't blame
obama's what about ism
except that it excuses the one flaw that
if fixed
could unify his party and this country
and that flaw is identity politics
which prefers disunity and differences
over mutual understanding
political power based on grievance
requires an endless
supply of oppressors without them
there's no power
no wonder young healthy individuals with
endless opportunities
feel and seem hopeless it's because the
anger
ruins them identity politics says you're
never going to win until you're the
oppressor
and that means embracing a
vengeance-based dogma
and it says that others no matter their
age are still guilty of a huge
historical crime against blacks women
gays you name it ultimately each group
will turn on itself
since one person's oppressor is
another's victim
and it removes forgiveness and
commonality replacing it with a
grievance drip
that leaves you unhirable and bitter
until the democrats discard this
obstacle to unity
it's only going to get worse hell it's
not often that i give advice
earnest advice to democrats what the
hell am i thinking
snap out of it i don't know what's going
on i gotta go one
i honestly believe i know we talk about
this all the time but you have to
believe that i believe this that this is
something that if the democrats let go
could be a magnificent thing for both
parties because it'll make the
republicans better as well if you have a
really
strong message a unifying message from
democrats
then it makes the republican everybody
becomes better because it's about
unification
i'm all for unification i think that
it's important to emphasize the idea
that we're all americans we have a
common destiny
but i do think contrary to what you said
that
you know i mean you left donald trump
out of there and i think he's a guy who
has found it politically advantageous to
divide us as americans and that
uh identity politics to my mind
especially then in politics of
today i think a lot of it begins with
things like birth or movement this guy's
the other he's really not an american
or those guys i wish he'd fire those
sons of [ __ ] who are kneeling the
black
football players i could go on in that
regard but you know this story
but to my eye to my mind what i'm seeing
right now is the emphasis that trump has
placed on white
identity politics and it's emboldened
people who i think in the past were
biting their tongues about it
but i think this is part greg of the
shifting demographics of the country
especially among young people more
people of color more
immigrants coming into the country and i
think it challenges
the idea of white majority and white
control
but you know what we need to get away
from that so that's where i agree with
you
and focus on things that bring us
together but i don't think trump is that
guy
well he maybe he isn't but identity
politics dana
stresses the differences stresses the
differences through this idea of
intersectionality
there's no way anybody can come together
if they're constantly competing on who's
more aggrieved
well and the thing is even if they're as
there are changing demographics in the
country it's even more important i think
than to go back to
and remind people and teach younger
people about uh
civics education and why the founders
founded our country
it's based on an idea so diversity is a
strength as is the democrats message
right
so okay well maybe you can see how far
you can get that way but
what would bring all of us together is a
reminder that
they focused america based on an ideal
that all men are created
equal but this is not about our heritage
it is not about a certain people that
that's why when macron
brought up nationalism at that speech uh
in france and
everyone thought it was a slam against
trump and maybe macron meant it that way
it's just listening to a few people
explain it better is that
nationalism in france like that yeah
absolutely that was bad like look what
happened yeah we get it when you talk
about nationalism in america it's not
based on an identity
in terms of you as a people it's based
on that we all agree on this ideal
that brought us together and that's
that's going to keep the country strong
going forward it's not just that
diversity is a strength it's that the
founding fathers
set us up for success and we should take
them up on it what do you think just
well just on juan's comment you talk
about trump saying they were sobs for
kneeling
i didn't see that as racial i saw that
as about patriotism and that was a
moment
where this whole country comes together
during the national anthem and trump
wanted everyone
to be united at that moment so i see it
a little bit differently
you know when obama was talking about
identity politics
he was brilliant at playing that game
and he was very effective
at it but it worked for him personally
but it didn't work for his party his
party got him
for eight years trying to do that takes
a very gifted and special politician
to pull that off the way he did now in
the democratic primary if it goes all
identity politics
it's useful against republicans but
against each other i think they're going
to cannibalize themselves
they're so diverse and there's going to
be so many candidates this year
you're going to have whites blacks
hispanics men women
cultural appropriators you're going to
have middle class millionaires native
americans
billionaires in there and i think some
people are going to try to weaponize
their identity and
say you're a straight white male in the
democratic party and you have other
candidates they're kind of subtly taking
digs at you
you're going to feel a little bit
resentment there and on the other hand
if you criticize
a black or hispanic or a female in the
democratic primary
and they're going to try to deflect and
maybe they'll play the gender card or
they'll play the race card
and they won't argue their points on
substance and that's going to
do him a disservice in the general now i
think what happened with hillary
she wasn't didn't play the gender card
when she was attacked by trump on policy
too much
she was pretty sharp on policy and i
have to give her some respect for that
obama didn't always play the victim you
know he was on the attack he was pretty
tough
i just think the the the culture and the
country
they're going to see 40 democrats
playing the victim
and whining can i say they're not gonna
they don't see winners there i think
they're gonna see losers i just wanna
say one thing but hillary's slogan
was not obviously it wasn't make america
great again i'm with her yeah
that was like the ultimate joke and she
has to play the gender cut i'm saying
you know
when trump goes after her on immigration
or trump goes after her
on health care she didn't say oh you
know you're attacking me
she really came back hard on policy all
right uh uh
jesse brought up the possibility of 40
candidates i'm going to throw to a uh
uh some sound on tape of julian castro
on msnbc discussing the immense number
of candidates take it away chris
what's it going to be like that 40
people running for president oh i think
we needed
actually on this side i think it's going
to be good for the party what happened
in 2016
wherever you were whichever camp you
were in there was a good amount of
bitterness after that campaign
i think it's going to be cathartic for
the the democratic party to go through
this process where as you say a lot of
talented people with great ideas
are going to run they're probably going
to be a lot of debates this time
jedidiah would do you agree that this
could be cathartic yeah
i like to see a lot of candidates on a
stage but i think it's going to be
challenging for them because you're
going to have people who completely
disagree with each other running for the
same
for the same position because the
democratic party is so split right now
and i'm curious to see
how they're going to make arguments like
like they like to make like against the
one percent for example when they have a
lot of people
in that lineup that could potentially be
billionaires themselves i mean
you're looking at mark cuban you're
looking at mike bloomberg i mean these
are people that are going to be tough
sales with the kind of messaging
that they often do i will say also just
on the identity politics that i agree
with you on i think both sides do do it
and i think there's a profound lack of
self-awareness on both sides when they
do it
but i think they do it because it does
work a lot i really do i think with
young voters i think that war on women
uh talk i think it when they went after
mitt romney on that binder is full of
women i think that really took him out
and i do think a lot of people are
receptive to it because when you
compartmentalize the country that's a
way that
democrats in particular i think made
people feel like they were being heard
like okay you're a woman these are your
issues particular to you
we're going to solve those issues for
you you know republicans are
anti-contraception
they're you know they don't want to
protect your right to choose and it
makes people
feel for a moment that they're being
heard and that that person is fighting
for them it really takes a second of
sitting back
and actually thinking about how divisive
and how divide and conquer it is to be
mad about it
i want okay that's true if there was a
party for short people
i would probably be like i'm ready to
listen you could be the leader
i could be the leader uh we will follow
we yes yes
you could be my vp or i wait that's
sexist i would be the beast
i'm imagining you both standing on
pedestals at the podium
party one i think we could get dana high
heels yeah there you go i know
the problem is i am wearing high heels
oh i didn't i'm sorry
if you want to talk about the 40 no i
just wanted to say oh the 40 doesn't
bother me
i agree with uh julian castro when he
said it could be cathartic
you know let a thousand flowers bloom i
don't think it's gonna include hillary
clinton but let a thousand
oh you don't think so that's no i don't
but i do think this that
the event last night where obama made
this statement was in houston
at the baker center at rice university
jim baker who you know secretary of
state
reagan all that kind of stuff he said
the prop what's the matter i just love
that like you know you know
baker you know that guy didn't i tell
people not i mean it's a long time ago
david people should know
okay so jim baker says the responsible
center in the
country's politics is disappearing obama
comes back and says
the internet plays to division in the
society makes
division sales i can sell you a division
in an instant
on the internet right yeah i agree i
just have one other point on the
on the 40. um so the democratic national
committee is going to have a pretty
strict way of figuring out how to get
out of this
problem so like if you're tom steyer and
your main issue
is impeaching donald trump and that's
what you want to run on i guarantee you
you are not going to make it to the
adult
debate you are not going to make it to
super tuesday they're going to figure
out a way to weed those people out
all right do you want to say anything
jesse before i tease no i think we have
to go sell some ads
okay